a new observation of the bending of
distant starlight by gravity has allowed
researchers to weigh a white dwarf star
virtually impossible before now for an
isolated star one of the key predictions
of Einstein's general theory of
relativity is that the curvature of
space near a massive body such as a star
causes a ray of light passing near it to
be deflected by twice the amount that
would be expected so when a star passes
between us and a more distant star we
should see the distant star shift
position or in the case of perfect
alignment become distorted into a
perfectly circular ring of light a
so-called Einstein rank one of the first
convincing proofs of general relativity
came in 1919 during an eclipse of the
Sun when astronomers saw its gravity
shift the position of stars close to its
edge in recent decades astronomers have
seen the gravity of galaxies produce
Einstein rings of more distant galaxies
and stars briefly brighten the image of
other stars in a process known as
gravitational microlensing but detecting
a position shift caused by a star other
than the Sun has been too small to
desert seeing such a shift would be very
useful to astronomers because it would
provide a way to directly measure the
mass of the intervening star something
that is very hard to do unless the star
is in a binary pair when their orbits
reveal their mass recently researchers
realized that the keen eyesight of the
hubble space telescope might be able to
spot such movement so was looking for
stars that might soon be in alignment
they found that the nearby white dwarfs
dying
20:51 B was set to pass nearly in front
of another star in March of 2014 they
then used Hubble to measure tiny shifts
in the apparent position of the
background star as Stein 20:51 be passed
by the researchers measurements put the
white dwarf stars mass to be about 0.675
solar masses as well as demonstrating
the power of this new technique the work
also solved an enigma surrounding Stein
2051 beat an earlier mass estimate had
made it substantially lighter to light
for a white dwarf of that type casting
doubt on the theory of how such earth
doubt stellar remnants form but the new
measurement puts Stein 20:51 B's mass
exactly where it should be with this one
measurement the researchers have
confirmed Einsteins prediction
demonstrated a valuable new technique
and reinforced the theory of stellar
evolution that's a good day's work
[Music]